simple practical award-winning products
for everyday use by Phoenix design that
can be found in countless homes all over
the world Tom shown here and andreas
Hogg founded the design company they are
fascinated with everyday life
I tagged you said this was an everyday
life concerns us constantly and we think
we can make all the things around us
better this among can see style but I'm
suffocating in samana we think a lot
about what might have changed and how
things are used about people's new or
changing needs and desires for products
in turn Andy put up down and for that I
think it's fascinating to find a new
function or new design is design I'll
try out a new kind of material alight
that's Hindi taspan endure their shower
head makes you feel like you're standing
in a downpour predicts is flat screen
TVs won several prizes renowned brands
have sold millions of phenix designed
products it's Maxum is that design
should be functional easy to operate and
enchanting
immaculate dentist ultimately the magic
is what excites a person what makes you
like a product and encourages you to use
it for a much longer time than something
you don't like Aang are open which ties
it was last minute Nissan you might even
keep using it once it's become
technically out of date Vincent tekniska
say in India I get communist
the vision of timeless functional design
brought under layers hog and Tom shown
how together in 1987 since then their
team has continually expanded now about
40 designers work on new products or
rework classics like water taps van de
mi vida you milady mitt we continually
have young people coming to us with
fresh ideas and completely different
approaches when daddy and I think this
mixture of spontaneity when different
views of things and our experience is
what results in successful things in
tasket then I had a year for agent again
sometimes a new project will generate a
hundred or more initial sketches then a
selection process begins this time the
team is deciding on a standing aid
office furniture is a new area for the
company again and again Phoenix adapts
everyday objects to meet people's needs
in 2012 hug and shown hair received a
federal German design award for their
life's work the same Carly we are
designers who shouted the market at the
top of our voices my paycheck we stand
out because of our quality and because
of our work and that makes me very proud
decided this this month mission says
towards the company is named after the
mythological bird that bursts into
flames and then rises again from its
ashes the idea don't stand still but
reinvent yourself again and again every
day life is a continual challenge
you